wo meine liebe luca heute ist der erste
dezember ich wünsche euch einen frohen
ersten advent der eigentlich schon
vorgestern war passend zur
weihnachtszeit habe ich für uns alle
einen adventskalender gekauft der mine
und das alter der luchs natürlich
perfekt geistig widerspiegelt playmobil
von daher öffnen wir im heutigen video
einfach mal das erste türchen und da
haben wir direkt die bier gilt die
birgit ist vom beruf tierärztin
meine lieben freundes habe mir das auch
endlich abgearbeitet weihnachtsstimmung
ist vorbei denn ihr hörte schon an der
musik und ihr könnt es auch
wahrscheinlich schon am titel und
tapenade nicht so aktuell haben wir
lange darauf gewartet falls ihr
vergessen haben sollte worum es bei tour
zu ende geht kein ding
ich hab's auch vergessen ach das sind ja
die grün lichter
was bedeuten noch mal die grünen lichter
ich glaube die haben ja alle so ein
armband um und wenn das grün leuchtet
dürfen die etwas miteinander haben weil
das ist ja eigentlich generell verboten
in der serie
also wenn die untereinander irgendwie
küssen oder irgendwie so kostet die das
geld wenn zwei menschen eine echte
verbindung aufgebaut haben bekommen sie
für begrenzte zeit grünes licht
jetzt gilt mit dem grünlich warum lag ja
nicht schon alle miteinander rum und
alle knutschen so braucht die uhr das ja
francesca das war auch ironie dass
besuchen
wenn du lust hast das man dir mal ironie
beibringt ich wohne jetzt in hamburg
nicht mehr in köln um mich besuchen
kommen das ist so schön deine es ist so
schön wenn ich nach draußen cook
der gashahn zu schneiden
ahlmann sven eines schnee
vom himmel fällt ich werde lana und ihre
lektion vermissen eine echte
bereicherung
die haben sich doch alle immer nur
ballade aufgeregt das ist das
staffelfinale und in 56 stunden müssen
unsere singles das paradies verlassen
in 56 koma da sind nur die zwei tote
deutlicher so werde ich das aber
eigentlich noch schöner ich denke schon
auch ans geld das teilt das ding davon
ist nicht mehr so viel übrig naja da
würde ich auch so gucken meine liebe
lampe
die war gar nicht die lampe oder
wo es tut mir so leid ich bin so raus
alter bevor sie ihre gäste wieder in die
echte welt entlässt mit lana den
gewinner verkünden was
es gibt gewinner von der serie ich
dachte dass das geld aufgeteilt wird
eine ahnung was lena vorhat wird es
einen sieger geben oder doch zwei
ich dachte alle und die machen das als
gruppe und nicht gegeneinander
da bin ich jetzt aber schon ein bisschen
enttäuscht oder was das wieder zu birgit
hier geht es in zwei teile hier
[Musik]
was denkt ihr schreibt jetzt die
kommentare ich denke
ich würde gar keine von denen das geld
geben alter 56 stunden bis zur
entscheidung
ich bin jetzt auch urlaub machen das ist
so frech alter hier der schnee schon
wieder weg das preisgeld das einst
stolze 100.000 dollar betrug ist auf
mickrige 43 riesen geschrumpft was
43 riesen oder mehr als die hälfte der
küste
komisch sich das anhört
wie kann man die schuhe an jedes mal
wenn harry und ich geld verlieren bringt
uns das näher zusammen und dass das
keiner sieht oder verstehen will macht
mich echt sein
naja ihr könnt halt auch einfach näher
zusammenkommen in dem ihr euch einfach
mehr zusammenkommt und nicht die ganze
zeit regelrecht von ceske und harry du
kannst du noch regeln brechen dann noch
mal mit mehreren hamburg bekommt es im
laden ich habe auch super dance kalender
fertig schon gebastelt
auch wenn mich einer so sieht werde ich
nie eine freundin kriegen apropos
romantik sharon und ronja haben sich
eine yacht und flasche schampus
ergattert was war deine hand warum haben
die plötzlich eine jacht und eine
flasche champagner
hey
das habe ich dann alles verpassen
letzten wochen diese reise werde ich nie
vergessen als ich hier ankam hatte ich
null vertrauen männer und jetzt immer
noch nicht das wird nur vertrauen und
schon morgen wollen weil er ein
absoluter ehrenmann war aber die ganze
staffel bisher aber so leute wie harry
also oder dieser andere mit den locken
b
ich habe alle den abend vergessen es tut
mir so leid aber die kann man nicht
sagen dass sie jetzt ihr vertrauen und
männer zurück als man weiß nie was
leider oder gott für eingeplant hat
planer ist immer nur lustig wenn man den
anglern rückwärts ausspricht
wir haben noch nicht darüber gesprochen
wie es dann weitergeht zeigen
[Musik]
ich habe bisher nicht mehr mit roller
zusammen sein will weil sie halt ein
kind schaum hat ich hätte nie gedacht
dass ich jemanden finden der mich so
verändern
ich weiß was ich zu tun das ist krass es
hier zum saufen
was sagst du dazu ansehen würde würde
ich ihm meine zunge so weil du bist du
michael wiemann kleine freundin sein
jetzt werdet so langsamer der zeitpunkt
wo ronda aber mit der sprache rausrücken
könnte ja ich will ein antrag war das
aber nicht ran da ja und was ist mit dem
sohn da wirst du so willst du mit mir
gehen aber erst mal muss sie von diesem
kaputt darunter com alter das wackelt ja
mehr als wenn sandra ins fahrschulauto
einsteigt es war seine größte angst
wieder eine beziehung einzugehen hat
sich für mich überwunden
die beiden werden safe gewinnen also
wenn roger und schon war das ding ich
gewinnen alter damit ich der kaiser von
china
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ab
das ab jetzt kann ich dann leider nicht
mehr mein video rein weil es sonst
wieder +18 wir danke youtube ich liebe
euch eines der größten hindernisse im
leben überwunden
sie ist das hirn zu meinem yang und
zusammen jetzt komm runter von dem
philosophen schiff es ist die letzte
folge und den produzenten gehen die
ideen aus
also bedienen sie nach einer reality tv
klischee
alle sind weiß angezogen haben eine
kerze in der hand das
was soll das
gläser rücken und beschwören geister
oder was und klar muss man überlegen
das war alles von krone
oh mann ich war mir so was
aber so viele freunde hatte ich noch nie
und da gibt es auch wenn ich gar nichts
vermissen lassen uns auch fantastische
beziehungen und tiefe verbindung anstoß
schön gesagt ihr habt eine so viel
gelernt wird das sind gar keine herzen
gläser das ist moscow mule oder die
trinken da alkohol im fernsehen ich bin
so ein tanzbär der tanz
ich
wird aber
mit einem spektrum lecken können
[Musik]